Heute im Rasenfunk?
Der blickt auf andere Menschen.
Jetzt nicht umschalten, ihr seid genau richtig, bzw. warum sollte man bei einem Podcast umschalten? Das fängt ja schon mal ganz fantastisch an. Herzlich willkommen hier im Rasenfunk zur Liga Tour. Hallo liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer und hallo liebe Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer auf YouTube. Schön, dass ihr eingeschaltet habt. Wir wollen heute sprechen über die Serie A, die Premier League und La Liga. Die Ligue 1 hat es leider nicht in die Liga Tour geschafft. Das hat aber rein terminliche Gründe, hat nichts mit der Liga zu tun. Ich freue mich sehr, dass ich hier begrüßen kann. Zum einen Christian Bernhardt. Hallo Christian. Außerdem Alex Treuker von unter anderem viva la liga.de. Hallo Alex. Und dann ist hier, wir haben ihn schon im September mal gehört, Hendrik Buchheister und wir können endlich sagen, nicht nur warum du deinem Namen alle Ehre gemacht hast, Hendrik, sondern auch warum du in der letzten Saison so selten in der Liga Tour warst. Hallo Hendrik. Ja, Herr Buchheister, warum waren Sie denn so selten da in der Liga Tour letzte Saison?
Also ich sage euch, am Wochenende vom 9. und 10. Dezember, da fallen die Entscheidungen, die hier in der Ligatur angekündigt wurden. Denn wir haben vorhin schon rausgearbeitet, dann wird Xabi entweder entlassen oder er hat die Wochen der Wahrheit durchbekommen. Und dann wird nämlich dieses, also Bournemouth, Manchester City und dann eben Arsenal. Und Arsenal ist eben am 9. Dezember das Spiel für ersten Villa. Dann wissen wir auch, wo Una Emery steht. Und ich muss sagen, wenn ich jetzt wählen könnte, ob wir eine Champions League haben wollen, mit Bologna, mit ersten Villa, ich würde sagen mit dem VfB Stuttgart, ja, go for it, bitte.
Also stop the count.
Ja, bei Girona war ich jetzt nicht ganz das Märchen, ehrlich gesagt, sorry. Da kann ich mich nicht zu sehr verbiegen. Aber ja. Seid mir ab, ich wäre mit dabei. Das wäre ja wirklich ganz, ganz fantastisch. So, wir haben es natürlich geschafft, hier trotzdem wieder in der Überlänge zu landen. Aber so ist das wahrscheinlich einfach bei uns. Aber wir wollen doch schnell unsere Awards vergeben. Das geht ja auch ein bisschen fixer. Das heißt, wie der MVP der aktuellen Phase, Unsung Hero der aktuellen Phase und Moment des letzten Spieltags oder was uns einfach so im Hirn geblieben ist. Du darfst anfangen. Alex, wer ist denn dein MVP aktuell?
Antoine Grießmann ist mein MVP. Sollte, hätte er eigentlich auch gut und gerne der MVP der letzten Saison sein können. Zumindest bei uns im Tikitaka-Podcast wurde er es. Für La Liga wurde Ter Stegen zum MVP der Saison gewählt. Auch nicht ganz unverdient, ne? Und deswegen muss ich hier mal ein Loblied auf Grießmann singen, was wir, glaube ich, in dieser Stelle noch nicht getan haben. Deswegen ist es überfällig. Er ist in herausragender Form, und zwar wirklich im ganzen Kalenderjahr 2023 und auch erst recht jetzt in der Saison, 13 Tore in 18 Spielen. Er ist wirklich der talisman, der Goalgetter von Atletico, der Seele, Herz, Motor, Maschinenraum, alles, was du willst. Kannst noch ein paar andere Wörter benutzen. Also wirklich Dreh- und Angelpunkt. 9 Tore in 13 Spielen in La Liga, 4 Tore in 5 Spielen in der Champions League, das ist ja herausragend. Das sind ja fast schon Haarland-Zahlen. Das kennt man ja eigentlich gar nicht. Bei Grießmann war er eigentlich gar nicht so bekannt dafür, dass er reinweise Tore schießt. Ich glaube, er hat noch nie in der Saison mehr als 15 geschossen, wenn ich mich nicht täusche. Also umso bemerkenswerter, dass er so viele schießt. Im fantastischen Form, wirklich eingebunden, wie kein anderer in seiner Mannschaft. Wenn du seine Heatmap anschaust, zum Beispiel, es gibt ja die eine Position, die er hat, gibt es gar nicht, weil er überall auf dem Feld ist und wirklich die komplette Heatmap ist hoch.
Weißt du, wie man das in Italien nennt?
In Spanien nennt man sowas ein Toto-Campista, also einen ganz Feldler, der auf dem ganzen Feld überall ist. Es ist wirklich grandios. Er obert Bälle im sechser Raum, lässt da prallen, spielt weiter, kämpft rechts außen, er obert dann den Ball, grätscht an der Seitenlinie, vorne macht er das Ding rein oder legt ab auf Morata. Also wirklich eine Freude, ihm zuzuschauen. Und ja, deswegen mein kleiner Geheimtipp, weil Barca-Kriesel ja, haben wir ja festgestellt, achtet auf Atletico in der Saison. Champions League, klar, weiß man nie, bei K.O.-Wettbewerb, aber in La Liga, da haben sie gute Chancen, mal nicht nur in den Top 3 zu landen, wie immer, sondern vielleicht auch mal ein bisschen weiter oben. Wenn Griesmann in der Form bleibt, gute Chancen.
Trotokampister, sehr schön. Aktuell vier Punkte hinter Girona und Real. Christian, wie haben wir ein Spiel weniger? Ah ja, stimmt, genau, richtig. Ganz genau.
Bei mir, der MVP, da kann sich jetzt die Brücke zu Griesmann schlagen. Ich fand, alles, was Alex gesagt hat, am zweiten Champions-League-Spiel, da war ja Atletico, in Bailazio. Und da habe ich es auch. Das war unfassbar auch sein Fußball-IQ von Griesmann. Da hat er auf Fassenweise in Hälfte 2 nur mit einem Kontakt gespielt. Und jedes Mal Räume geöffnet.
Jetzt hat Jürgen Klinsmann auch.
Das war wirklich herausragend. Weil die Zahlen sind ja schon Wahnsinn, die Alex anspricht. Aber ich finde jetzt auch weg von den Toren. Also so viel Fußball-IQ ist mir extrem hängen geblieben. So, und jetzt schließt sich der Kreis zu Lazio. Denn MVP steht ja für Most Valuable Player, wie wir alle wissen. Und da muss ich momentan Giro Immobile nennen. Es ist unfassbar. Also Lazio, dazu muss man sagen, in der Liga stehen sie alles andere als gut. Da glaube ich nur 17 Punkte, Rang 11 hinter Fro Sinone und Monza. Also zum vergessen. Aber in der Champions League sind sie jetzt eben schon einen Spieltag vor Schluss fürs Achtelfinale qualifiziert in einer Gruppe mit Atletico und auch Fairnord. Und Fairnord ist eine richtig starke Mannschaft, die jetzt sicherlich nicht den großen Namen hat. Aber dass Lazio in dieser Konstellation schon einen Spieltag vor Schluss durch ist, hätte ich nicht damit gerechnet. Und es hat damit zu tun, dass am Dienstag, also gegen Fairnord vor zwei Wochen, hat Immobile das 1-0, das Entscheidende gemacht. Es blieb beim 1-0 und jetzt am Dienstag gegen Celtic. 0-0 lange Zeit, 75. Immobile kommt am Ende 2-0, beide Tore Immobile. Also er ist wirklich so was wie die Lebensversicherung schlechthin. Dieses Tor gegen Fairnord war sein 200. Pflichtspieltor für Lazio. Also für einen Verein, da können dann, glaube ich, nur Lewandowski und... Also es gibt, glaube ich, nur drei oder vier in Europa aktive Spieler, die das momentan vorweisen können für einen Verein. Und er ist auch in den letzten sechs Lazio-Spielen. Hat Lazio nur, hat Immobile alle Tore für Lazio erzielt. Da kann man jetzt drüber reden, dass das logisch nicht gut für Lazio ist. Aber es zeigt eben für mich, ein MVP ist eben der, der den großen Unterschied für seine Mannschaft macht. Und das macht Immobile. Und wie gesagt, allein die Champions League-Quali fürs Achtelfinal, da reden wir ja auch über viel Geld. Das tut Lazio sehr gut. Und dementsprechend, auch wenn Lazio in der Liga sehr enttäuschend da steht, ist er für mich Kommandar um ihn, nicht drumrum.
Stark, Ciro Immobile, das ist doch schön. Und wen darf ich für die Premier League aufschreiben, Hendrik?
Ich würde, wenn das okay ist, vielleicht die Kategorien so ein bisschen verlassen stattdessen, weil ich jetzt nicht gewusst hätte, wie ich das ansonsten hätte einordnen können, ganz kurz einen kleinen Nachruf vortragen auf Harry Venables, über den ich vielleicht ganz kurz was sagen würde. Der gestorben ist am Wochenende im Alter von 80 Jahren und der vor allem in England bekannt ist als Nationaltrainer der Engländer bei der EM 1996, die für ganz viele Engländer vor allem, ich würde mal sagen so Mitte 30 bis Mitte 40, so das fußballerische Erweckungserlebnis waren und das Sommermärchen, also im Vergleich zu Deutschland 2006 drängt es ja so ein bisschen auf. Der Fußball war nicht überragend, weil man hatte halt diese Vielgutstimmung im Land. Man hat die Niederlande geschlagen, 4-1 ist dann bekanntlich dramatisch an Deutschland geschaltet, im halbfinale Elfmeterschießen. Und von Venebels in Erinnerung geblieben ist aber dieses Bild, wie er nach dem Elfmeterschießen Gareth Southgate tröstet und Southgate also wirklich komplett konsterniert ist und wahrscheinlich auch in dem Wissen, was so in den nächsten Tagen in der Öffentlichkeit auf ihn einprasseln wird. Venebels steht da und redet auf ihn ein und lächelt dabei die ganze Zeit, als wäre das halt überhaupt nicht schlimm, was Southgater passiert ist. Und das ist, was tatsächlich alle, also in allen Nachrufen, alle Ex-Spieler, die sich äußern, was hier bei Venebels sagen, ist, dass ein total warmherziger Mensch war, ein total gutes Verhältnis zu seinen Spielern hatte, eine Art väterlicher Freund auch, der für den Fußball in England wahnsinnig viel getan hat und vor allem immer mit dieser EM96, diesem Summer of Love, in Verbindung gebracht werden wird und er ist, wie gesagt, am Wochenende gestorben und das wollte ich ganz gerne erwähnen.
Ja, sehr schön. Das finde ich auch sehr passend. Werde ich die Kategorie irgendwie umbenennen, beziehungsweise ach, die Hörerinnen und Hörer wissen ja, was gemeint ist, wenn dann mal diese Art von MVP hier auftaucht. Wen schreiben wir denn als Unsung Hero in die Liste, Alex, bei La Liga?
Einen alten Bekannten, den Hero des spanischen Fußballs, Sergio Ramos möchte ich da gerne nennen. Denn er ist endgültig zurück in La Liga und bei Sevilla ist er so richtig angekommen, und zwar nicht nur, weil er jetzt ein Tor geschossen hat gegen Eintrofen, wenn auch nicht per Kopf, aber in La Liga ist er richtig angekommen, indem er das gemacht hat, was er am allerliebsten tut, nämlich rote Karten sammeln. Er hat mal wieder einen Platzverweis bekommen und nicht nur, dass er einen bekommen hat, ist einfach eine schöne Story. In Anführungszeichen für ihn weniger schön für uns Betrachter, etwas amüsanter schön, sondern auch die Art und Weise. Er hat einen am eigenen Strafraum, einen Gegner abgegrätscht und dann gab es, er war schon gelb vorbelastet, dann gab es die gelb-rote vom Schiedsrichter und wie man das in Spanien natürlich so macht, wie das USOS ist, rannten nicht nur Ramos, sondern auch vier, fünf andere Sevillanos auf den Schiedsrichter zu und redeten auf ihn ein, er zürt und nein, das war kein gelb und schauste bitte nochmal an, offenbar. Also Ramos und Co. baten den Schiedsrichter doch bitte zum Bildschirm zu gehen. Dieser ging zum Bildschirm, sah sich die Szene an, strich seine gelbe Karte und zeigte ihm aber glatt rot, denn er war letzter Mann und hat den Gegner auch oberhalb des Knöchels mit gestrecktem Bein erwischt, also statt gelb gab es dann rot, weil Ramos ihn gebeten hat, bitte schaust du nochmal an. Also auch eine sehr, sehr kuriose, amüsante, muss man schon sagen, rote Karte und damit sammelt er weiter seine roten Karten, denn grandiose Statistik, wirklich fantastisch. Deswegen ist er ein Hero, der hier besungen werden muss. Es war seine neunundzwanzigste rote Karte in seiner Karriere. Seit dem Jahr 2000 hat der Spieler auf Platz zwei übrigens, ein alter Bekannter, Thiago Motta, sechzehn rote Karten gesammelt und Ramos neunundzwanzig. Also eine gewisse Diskrepanz da und deswegen ist er einfach ein Hero, Ramos.
Ich habe diese Szene schon beschrieben bekommen in einem anderen Podcast mit dem Gelb-Rot. Was ich jetzt aber erst sehe, ist, dass Jesus Navas dann auch noch eine rote Karte bekommen hat. Weil sie so draufgegangen sind auf den Schiedsrichter oder dann nachdem dann von Gelb-Rot zu Rot. Fantastisch. Es gibt ja jetzt vom IFAB die Überlegung, dass in einem Testlauf nur noch, ja also Zeitstrafe so eingeführt werden und nur noch der Kapitän des Teams soll in bestimmten Situationen mit dem Schiedsrichter sprechen dürfen, so wie man es aus dem Rugby ja zum Beispiel kennt.
Viel Glück in Spanien und Italien.
Ah komm, jetzt wollen wir hier mal nicht diese Klischees be-besühen, aber du, also sorry, da hat der VfL Bochum genauso große Probleme wie jede italienische Mannschaft. Das können Fußballspieler einfach nicht.
Ja, weil sie es nicht müssen, weil sie ja nicht bestraft werden. So wird ja der Kreistraß, so schließt er sich ja. Deswegen ja, wäre eine Überlegung wert auf jeden Fall, aber für Spanien ist das schwer umsetzbar, weil das gehört da zum guten Ton, zur Kultur, dass man da auf den Schiedsrichter einbrescht und einredet und einstürmt.
Wir sprechen uns nochmal in ein paar Jahren. Vielleicht bekommt man dann deswegen auch so einen Topin als Schiedsrichter da raus. Wenn du in so einer Kultur Schiedsrichter großziehst, sag ich jetzt mal, dann muss vielleicht auch von der Gegenseite ein bisschen mehr Dramaturgie reinkommen in alle Entscheidungen. Also ich hoffe, da tut sich noch ein bisschen was. Dann schauen wir mal in die Serie A. Wer ist da dein unsang Hero?
Mein hat jetzt nicht so einen großen Namen wie Sergio Ramos. Kennen vielleicht nicht so viele. Es geht um Alberto Dossena, das ist ein Innenverteidiger von Caliari. Bis vorletzte Saison hat der dritte Liga gespielt, war nicht groß im großen Fußball. Letzte Saison hat er dann mit Caliari Serie B, als er zweite Liga gespielt, war jetzt auch alles anders als Stammspieler, ist mit Caliari aufgestiegen und jetzt ist er plötzlich absoluter Stammspieler bei Caliari in der Innenverteidigung und hat zuletzt zweimal getroffen. Caliari in den letzten Wochen auch unter Sir Claudio Ranieri auf der Insel der Trainer. Caliari ist sehr schlecht gestartet, aber mittlerweile hat sich im Moment von den Abstiegsrängen zwar nur ein Punkt Vorsprung, aber sie sind aktuell nicht auf dem Abstiegsrang, weil sie zuletzt am Wochenende Torsena getroffen haben, sie gegen Monza unentschieden gespielt, dann haben sie gegen FC Genoa ein direktes Duell davor gewonnen, gegen Juve hat er zuletzt auch ein Kopfballtor erzielt, wo Juve dann auch am Ende nochmal Probleme hätte, weil es 2-1 dann war und eng und Kaljeri eng dran war. Und vor kurzem, das war dieses wilde Fosinone-Spiel, auch ein direkter Konkurrent, da lag Kaljeri zu Hause 0-3 zurück bis zur 70. Minute und hat am Ende noch 4-3 gewonnen durch zwei Tore in der Nachspielzeit und das Viertenteentscheidende hat er vorbereitet. Also er ist jetzt damit auch als Innenverteidiger, hinter dem Marco glaube ich der Scoringstärkste Verteidiger der Liga, zwei Tore, eine Vorlage und ja wie gesagt eine kleine Figur, die man so nicht auf den Zettel hatte, die wie gesagt lange dritte Liga gespielt hat und jetzt mit Kaljeri zumindest wieder mittendrin ist im Rennen, nicht gegen den Abstieg, fand ich einen Namen, den man sicherlich nicht oft hört, der aber zeigt, dass man eben auch vielleicht über den zweiten Bildungsweg, nenne ich es jetzt mal, dann auch trotzdem in der höchsten Liga eine wichtige Figur sein kann, weil er jetzt unabhängig von den Toren auch einfach Stammspieler in dieser Abwehr ist und der Ich bin der Raniere und dementsprechend da sicherlich alles probieren wird, damit Kaljeri am Ende nicht wieder runter muss.
Und man muss ja sagen, zwei Tore bei einem Team, das insgesamt nur 13 erzielt hat.
Sehr gut.
Irgendwann müssen wir auch mal darüber sprechen hier in der Liga Tour. Empoli 8 Tore in 13 Spielen, Verona 9 Tore, Salah nitana 10, Lecce 10, wenn ich es hier gerade richtig... ne, Entschuldigung, Torino 10. Lecce hat immerhin 15, Udinese nur neun, also geht mehr, aber gut, ja sehr schön. Alberto Dossena, den merken wir uns ab jetzt. Dann Hendrik, nachdem du uns ja quasi Unsung Hero und MVP in einem geliefert hast, darfst du mal deinen Moment der Woche nennen. Was war der?
Ja, ist relativ einfach und jetzt sprechen wir doch noch über Manchester United, ist natürlich das Tor von Alejandro Ganacho.
Genau, kein so schnickendes Tor gegen Everton am Wochenende.
Everton, wie gesagt, die großer Fan-Protest vorher und Stadion natürlich extrem aufgepeitschend. Dann noch drei Minuten Flanke von rechts, Dallo in die Mitte. Ganacho muss auch noch ein paar Schritte zur Seite machen, um sich entsprechend unter den Ball zu positionieren. Und dann Fallrückzieher, trifft den Ball wirklich perfekt. Und schlägt oben rechts im Winkel ein über Pickford, Pickford, keine Chance. Und das ist wahrscheinlich nicht nur der Moment der Woche, sondern ziemlich sicher das Tor der Saison. Und es wurden natürlich auch direkt Vergleiche angestellt mit anderen schönen Toren und vor allem Fallrückzieher-Toren. Da fällt dann als Vergleichsgröße immer Wayne Rooney ein gegen Manchester City. 2011 war es, glaube ich, Rooney aber den Ball mit dem Schienbein trifft, also auch nicht hundertprozentig perfekt. Also ist jetzt natürlich Klagen auf hohem Niveau, schon klar, aber dieses Garnaccio Tor ist der perfekte Fallrückzieher, das perfekte Tor und zeigt halt auch, dass bei Manchester United schon auch noch Potenzial da ist. Also Garnaccio ist 19 Jahre alt, spielt seine zweite Saison, hat jetzt auch gegen Galatasaray getroffen und ja, also ganz klar Moment der Woche, mindestens.
Aber absolut, solltet ihr es noch nicht gesehen haben, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, dann googelt das oder gebt es in eine Suchmaschine eurer Wahl ein absolut fantastisches Tor.
Du musst einen Einspieler wieder reinholen.
Aber es war wirklich der perfekte Fallrückzieher, weil er ihn perfekt erwischt, weil er ihn auch quasi am höchsten Punkt erwischt und weil er ihn gerade noch so erwischt und weil er ihn dann aber auch so ins Tor macht, dass du jetzt auch nicht denkst, du hast ja auch manchmal Fallrückzieher, wo du das Gefühl hast, wäre der Torhüter jetzt nicht überrascht davon gewesen, dass aus dieser Situation ein Schuss wird, dann hätte er ihn gehalten. Bei diesem Tor auf gar keinen Fall.
Ich weiß, warum du dir das Tor so feierst, weil eine flanke Punkt genau ankam.
Genau, er war auch ganz schön frei.
Die flanke kam allerdings auch nicht punktgenau an.
Sie war ja eigentlich zu hoch, deswegen musste er ja diesen Wahnsinns-Fallrückzieher machen.
Die Flanke war halt einigermaßen auf Verdacht in die Mitte gespielt und der Nachhüter Sieg und auch in der Wiederholung muss tatsächlich noch Zeit machen, um sich zu positionieren. Aber das sind jetzt Kleinigkeiten, also es ist tatsächlich, wie ihr sagt, der perfekte Fallrückzieher.
Also genau, wenn ich schon eine ungenaue Flanke fahre, dann wissen Sie, was die Stunde geschlagen hat. Deswegen einfach absolut fantastisch und seien wir ehrlich, damit wird niemand mit halten können, außer Alex hat jetzt aus La Liga hier noch irgendwie was ganz Besonderes, was ich nicht mitbekommen habe.
Nee, ich habe kein Tor, keine Aktion, sondern ich will auch eine Personalien nochmal nennen. Irgendwie roter Faden bei mir ist ja immer Trainerpersonalien und wir hatten das Thema Rückkehrer in La Liga mit Sergio Ramos. Ein weiterer Rückkehrer in La Liga ist Marcelino Garcia Toral, der Trainer, der jetzt zu Villarreal zurückgekehrt ist, war ja am Anfang der Saison bei Marseille und hat ja nach sieben Spielen hingeworfen, das macht man bei Marseille ja offenbar so, und ist jetzt zu Villarreal zurückgekehrt, hat seinen Einstand gefeiert am Wochenende mit dem 3 zu 1-Sieg gegen Osasuna und ist deswegen eine erwähnenswerte Personalie, weil er ja schon bei Villarreal war. Von 2013 bis 2016 hat er die recht erfolgreich gecoacht und wurde deswegen auch als Rückkehrer gefeiert. Villarreal hat das auch natürlich so marketingtechnisch schön romantisierend ins Bild gestellt und willkommen zu Hause in deinem Haus etc. etc. Und wie gesagt, Traumstart mit einem 3 zu 1-Sieg. Villarreal ist ja eine weitere Mannschaft, ähnlich wie Sevilla, die ja durch die Saison schlingern und komplett ihren den Faden verloren haben, den sportlichen und man hofft natürlich, dass jetzt auch schon der zweite, der dritte Trainer in der Saison, Setién ging ja und deswegen, ja, Pacheta war dann ein Nachfolger, wurde auch entlassen, deswegen auch wieder da. Thematik neuer Trainer soll für bessere Zeiten sorgen, aber die Hoffnung ist groß, denn Marcelino hat einen sehr hohen Punkteschnitt, den zweitbesten in der Vereinshistorie von Villarreal. Wer hat den besten Punkteschnitt? Was glaubt ihr? Der Name ist heute schon gefallen, war bei Villarreal als Coach, ob wir es leben. Ganz genau. Das ist der, der ich glaube, also Marcelino hat glaube ich 1,72 und Emery 1,75, also minimal, aber eben zeigt, da sieht man schon auf, die Hoffnungen bei Villarreal sind natürlich groß, dass unter Marcelino sie ja endlich wieder einen Schritt nach oben in der Tabelle machen können und sich stabilisieren können.
Stark, sehr gut. Auch, dass Marcelino noch jemand anderes ist, als der Spieler dabei hat, er gespielt hat. Das weckt auch noch mal Erinnerungen. Aber jetzt will ich nicht auch hier das noch günstig in die Länge ziehen. Christian, was schreiben wir bei dir als Moment der Woche auf?
Ja, der gibt sich in Italien auch relativ von alleine. Was hatten wir gerade? Garnaccio ist 19, oder?
Richtig.
In Italien hat am Wochenende im Milan-Dress ein gewisser Francesco Camarda sein Debüt gefeiert und zwar im Alter von 15 Jahren und ich glaube 8 Monaten. Er ist jetzt der jüngste Serie A-Spieler aller Zeiten, hat bei Milan einen gewissen Paolo Maldini sozusagen den Rekord abgenommen, der mit 16 debütiert hat und echt wunderschöne Bilder. Es war ein Milan-Heimspiel gegen die Fiorentina und es stand schon im Raum, weil Giroud war gesperrt, Okafor und Leao verletzt, Jovic hat angefangen und es stand schon in Tagen davor, wenn er einberufen wird, womöglich kriegt er seine ersten Minuten. Wunderbar, San Siro, die Kurve hat schon während dem Spiel Sprechchöre für ihn, also der ist in der Milan-Jugend groß geworden, sagt, das ist sein großer Traum und wunderbar, als er zum Einwärmen geschickt wurde, hat er die Chöre aus der Kurve mitgesungen. Also echt wunderbare Bilder, er hat einfach, er hat danach gesagt, er kann logisch alle Chöre, er kennt alle auswendig und hat das gesungen und als er dann reinkam, ich glaube in der Minute 82 oder 83, eine riesen Ballyhoo in San Siro, ihm hast du er gelächelt, als er reingelaufen ist, also wirklich so eine kindliche Freude und jetzt gab es einzelne Stimmen in Italien, die auch gemeint haben, boah, muss man einen 15-Jährigen reinwerfen, das kann man definitiv auch kritisch sehen, aber ich würde sagen Stefano Piorli, der Trainer von Milan, ist einer, der ein unfassbar gutes Gespür für auch Sachen, die über den Fußball hinausgehen, zur Erinnerung, er war der Trainer der Fiorentina, als Davide Astori verstorben ist, der wirklich einen sehr, sehr guten Draht, sehr gutes menschliches Gefühl hat und ich würde Piorli nicht unterstellen, dass er das aus Marketing-Zwecken getan hat, quasi um da jetzt irgendwie einen Rekord aufzustellen, sondern Piorli hat auch danach gesagt, für Talent gibt es kein, Talent hat kein Alter, so hat er es genannt, hat er gesagt, der Junge hat unfassbares Talent, eine Zahl dazu, es heißt, er hat bis jetzt knapp 90 Er hat knapp 90 Jugendspiele bestritten und das heißt, er hat um die 490 Tore da erzielt. Klar, das sind diese Geschichten, die kennen wir von früher auch, wenn dann die Mini-MBP ist und Mini-Messes eben rumlaufen. Deswegen, ich will jetzt auch nicht, die Geschichte ist ja logisch auch die, man soll dem Jungen auch nicht zu viel Verantwortung auferlegen, aber ich würde den Piolli-Faktor da wirklich nicht außen vor lassen, weil Piolli hat ein sehr gutes menschliches Gespür und deswegen würde ich eben diese Marketing-Nummer eigentlich fast bei Piolli ausklammern. Er durfte jetzt gegen Dortmund am Dienstag, weil ja da auch wieder Personal sehr wenig war, durfte er noch gar nicht spielen, weil in der Champions League die Regel gilt, unter 16 darfst du nicht spielen. Dementsprechend wird er aber sicherlich wahrscheinlich die nächsten Wochen auch immer wieder mal auf der Bank sitzen und die anderen Spieler haben auch gesagt, er ist unfassbar reif für sein Alter. Auch Piolli hat gesagt, der ist kein 15-Jähriger sozusagen, obwohl er noch 15 im Pass stehen hat und dementsprechend schauen wir mal, was da die nächsten Wochen und Monate daraus wird. Er ist ein Riesentalent und das war wirklich, wie gesagt, allein dieses Bild, er läuft zum Aufwärmen und singt die Chöre mit ein wunderbares Bild.
Also ich sehe schon bis zur 82. Minute hattest du noch keinen Moment der Woche und dann hast du Piolli gefragt, kann man da noch was machen? Und er hat geantwortet, ja, kann man. Und gleichzeitig gibt das uns allen auch Hoffnung, wenn Talent kein Alter kennt, dann fühle ich mich, weiß nicht warum, gleich viel, viel besser.
Was dann noch alles möglich ist.
Also wirklich, ab jetzt ist nur noch der Horizont das neue Limit. Ach, egal. Ihr drei, ich danke euch sehr, sehr herzlich. Das hat große Freude gemacht, mal wieder auf die Europäischen Ligen zu gucken. Ganz herzlichen Dank an Alex Treuker. Ich werde verlinken, wo man dir folgen kann und auf Viva la Liga kann man dich lesen und im Tikitaka Podcast kann man dich hören. Danke, dass du mal wieder mit dabei warst. Herzlichen Dank an Hendrik Buchheister. Kauft alle sein Buch. We Call It a Klassiker, die Engländer, der Fußball und wir erschienen bei Pieper. Wunderbares Weihnachtsgeschenk. Danke dir, Hendrik, dass du mal wieder mit dabei warst. Und herzlichen Dank natürlich an Christian Bernhardt hier an meiner Seite. Nicht in allen sozialen Netzwerken vertreten, das wird immer noch hin und wieder thematisiert von Hörern und Hörern, denen du fehlst, aber...
Kritisiert auch.
Kritisiert. Ja, aber wenn wir sehen, was für ein zufriedener Mensch er ist, dann kann man eigentlich auch nur sagen, warum haben wir das nicht getan. Also danke dir, Christian, dass du mit dabei warst.
Danke, Max, für die Einladung.
Und euch, lieben Hörern und Hörern, danke ich für die Aufmerksamkeit. Empfehlt den Rasenfunk gerne weiter, bewertet uns auf den Plattformen eurer Wahl und unterstützt uns auf rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Könnt ihr diesem supporters club beitreten. Auf kiosk.rasenfunk.de könnt ihr für Weihnachten shoppen und darüber hinaus natürlich. Und dann herzlichen Dank für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Bleibt gesund und geht mal auf rasenfunk.de, denn es gibt eine Fülle an Sendungen, die ihr hören könnt. Allein zur Bundesliga sind zwei diese Woche erschienen und es geht ja täglich eigentlich bei uns weiter. Danke fürs Zuhören, bis bald mal wieder hier im Rasenfunk. Macht's gut, ciao.
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen.